Mila Kunis had the perfect response  after a fan confused her for Megan Fox  in a now viral clip from September the  actors can be seen signing autographs  outside the Jimmy Kimmel Live studio in  New York City when one person asked her  to put her signature on a poster of the  Jennifer's Body star I love her that's  Megan Fox  fantastic Mila was happy to sign a  photograph for almost every fan except  for someone who was holding an old shot  of her wearing a swimsuit  Mila who was wearing a mask at the time  also posed for a selfie with a fan  before making her exit this isn't the  first time that fans have confused Mila  for another celebrity while appearing on  the Kelly Clarkson show back in  September 2021 Modern Family star Sarah  Hyland recalled how she was mistaken for  Mila on the Golden Globes red carpet  she is so much more important than I am  I know that's not true so much